[Musica]
prima di cominciare volevo chiedervi una
piccola cosa prima di cominciare io
siccome non sono certo tempo alla fine
perché il tempo è contato vi chiederò
adesso se vi è piaciuto il talk faccio
una storia instagram
come dite sì è stupendo va bene perché
tanto sui social non c'è mai la verità
quindi possiamo mentire spudoratamente
che va bene mentite vi è piaciuto e the
top mi piacete falsi bellissimo allora
io scusate c'è una zanzara che mi gira
intorno ed è una cosa che non sono
piaciute nella vita e uccidere le
zanzare quindi credo sia nella mia
piccola mission impossibile come te
visto parlo veloce nel cambio discorso
gesticolo tutte cose terribili per chi
sta su un palco a meno che come nel mio
caso lo fa il comico perché mi
conoscesse sono roberto tiberi faccio il
comico è iniziato in attacco uno
studente medicina ha fatto tre anni di
medicina poi ho lasciato per fare questo
ma che deve avere salvato molte più vite
non facendo quando dovevo dire a mia
madre che faceva questo mestiere non è
stato facile perché questo è un ricorso
con mestiere perché non è un mestiere
come tutti gli altri perché l'unico
mestiere che ti chiedono per strada di
riprodurlo dice sei nomi come la faina
battuta è come se io dico se l'ingegnere
mi fa un palazzo
se pizzaiolo ma fa la margherita 6
pugile bravo continua così quando devo
dire vincitore facevo il comico mio
padre ha detto un amico se faceva uno
spacciatore che se la fase quindi non è
preso benissimo come come mestiere è
però sono felice di averlo fatto io ho
incominciato quando lasciò medicina
dovevo dimostrare che questo era un
lavoro e quindi comincio a fare le
pizzerie io facevo gli spettacoli dentro
le pizzerie e questo mi ha insegnato a
parlare così veloce ovviamente sto
parlando molto veloce perché dovevo
andare più veloce del cameriere
perché se le camere dice a margherita
momento in cui sto dicendo la battuta
mela bruciava quindi devo andare più
veloce ho imparato da tempo a diventare
diciamo così celere nel parlare però
avevo un piccolo difetto nel senso che
volevo fare un termino tipo di comicità
volevo fare satira volevo fare come
questa un po più alta di quella che si
fa solitamente nelle pizzerie ma non
potevo perché ho 17 anni quando
incominciato e quindi non mi davano
l'autorità e potrei parlare di quelle
cose che guardavano dicevano ma questo
qui non può non avevo credibilità ero
poco credibile così per fortuna arriva a
salvarmi la vita
il web è esattamente facebook cominciò a
fare video sul web e in cui parlava di
cose
commentando i fatti che avvenivano nel
mondo parlava di cose anche che non
erano del tutto economiche male rendevo
comiche questo mi ha dato una
credibilità tale potere poco a poco
crearmi un minimo pubblico poi ho fatto
televisione poi sono uscito addirittura
a fare un film oggi faccio con mestiere
che amo e che mi fa vivere bene che
appunto uno spacciatore
ma il primo nemico che ho incontrato
facendo il web è stato lighters cioè
tutto bello nel web perché mi ha dato la
notorietà ma fare il comico sul web è
complicato perché incontri haters io
nella mia vita facendo parlando di
politica e tematiche complicato ricevuto
minacce di morte offese tipiche eccetera
eccetera di tutto e di più ma ancora più
grave delle the r's dell'argomento di
come lo parlare oggi è l'analfabeta
funzionale allora c'è una caratteristica
l'italia è al secondo posto per
alfabetico funzionare nel mondo che un
bel primato quasi primato che abbiamo è
bello a dire che era un alfabeto
funzionale e quello che non capisce non
riesce a distinguere il vero dal falso e
non riesce a capire quello che legge
tecnicamente quello che casca alle fake
news che ci sono sul web è per un comico
una fata funzionale vuol dire quello che
non riesce a capire l'ironia quindi fare
battute su internet è molto complicato
perché ti incontri con gente che non ha
idea che tu stai facendo una battuta un
paradosso
un esempio della cometa funzionale e mio
cugino cugino veramente più grande in
effetti fu sede del mondo e la notte
racconta un aneddoto lo scritto una
vecchia barzelletta la scritta sul web
che è andata in america e in america
appena il detto che ero siciliano
sicilia allora mafioso detto ma che
c'entra solo se ci sono tutti mafiosi e
poi si sa se tutti ma è stato veramente
non è vero sto fatto se si può in
sicilia se tutti ma perché non è che a
parte che assoluto perché tutte così a
tutti minchia ciò dovuto sparare
scrivo questa cosa è il mio cugino mi
commenta ma ti hanno arrestato allora ho
capito che c'era un nemico grandissimo
analfabeta funzionale ora se per il
comico una fetta funzionale è un
problema per tutti e non un problema
ancora più grande perché chi sta
investendo su reti funzionali sono i
grandi del mondo non è più trump in
america da noi
salvini cioè creano ad hoc del perché
salvini fa sempre ridere e crea una dock
delle fake news del creato ad hoc delle
fettine osé per pilotare il pensiero
della gente perché tu pensa la gente che
non riesce a capire che quella la
notizia falsa è influenza bellissimo ma
tutti siamo influenza bilisim e cioè se
qualcuno comincia temi tutto il giorno
formaggio formaggio formaggio formaggio
formaggio il mio cervello per quanto un
cervello allenato a un certo punto
cominciano a pensare al modello di
formaggio 16 blu blu blu blu blu un
certo punto con ci pensano di vedere blu
semplice cretino cretino cretino che
comincia a vedere al mio cugino cioè il
principio è che noi siamo tutti
influenza bill e quindi chi ha il potere
di gestire le fettine usa un potere
immane perché può farti credere che c'è
un problema anche se come la noce puoi
farti credere che c'è un problema che lo
risolve perché tanti problemi non è mai
esistito poi faccio addirittura credere
che c'è la crisi così può aumentare le
tasse e ora questo per esempio non vedo
perché realtà c'è veramente la crisi e
amici ma che mangia il cibo di tre
giorni prima per risparmiare ho visto
donne mettersi i vestiti un anno prima
per risparmiare addirittura un amico di
mio padre todt a fare l'amore con sua
moglie per risparmiare c'è più
quindi questo però cosa che mi preoccupa
ame amef hahahaha scusate la cosa che mi
fa prodotti arrabbiare è il fatto che
noi non ci rendiamo conto di quello che
stiamo combinando cioè stiamo vivendo la
più grande rivoluzione tecnologica nella
storia
noi abbiamo da circa due decenni e non
ci rendiamo conto che non ha nessuno di
noi ha un libretto d'istruzioni adesso
lo sa come gestirlo questo cast
cellulare nessuno sa come formare
evitare di formare dei nuovi analfabeti
funzionali è come sempre quando ho fatto
la rivoluzione industriale fu inventata
l'automobile è giustamente inventano la
scuola guida ma pensate se non
alimentare cioè più che l'automobile o
inventato l'auto scontro perché uscivamo
e ci prendiamo tutti quindi non lo
stesso principio identico
bisogna dire che ha tratto quando
limitata un'automobile noi italiani
eravamo un po più avanti perché i
tedeschi ben si inventa l'automobile
quindi per andare dal suo amico frank
faceva 400 km con l'automobile
citofonava dice frank e scendi no ma
come dove l'accento che non mi chiamava
a farlo
in italia invece meucci inventa per
telephone faceva tutto pronto franco
cellino tutto eravamo un po
più il allora mi sono chiesto come è
possibile dove l'errore è giusto che noi
ci arrabbiamo con gli analfabeti
funzionari no non è colpa dei mali che
funziona colpa è nostra
noi abbiamo un mezzo che io adoro e che
stimo tanto che la scuola dove invece di
insegnare la media ducation cioè
l'utilizzo e cioè la rai per evitare la
formazione nuova nella fede funzionale
così che io possa fare battute e che
quelli e possono votare coscientemente 9
la sprechiamo l'occasione perché
sequestriamo cellulari diciamo andiamo
in sala informatica dove il computer è
molto più obsoleto del cellulare che c'è
lo stesso ragazzo è la cosa peggiore è
che noi diamo il cellulare al bambino a
ricreazione che invece al momento in cui
dovrebbe parlare di compagni se ne trova
lì col cellulare
noi stiamo creando dei piccoli mostri
non ci rendiamo conto che fin da piccoli
anche quando quando ci abbiamo a casa
abbiamo difficoltà a comunicare perché
noi come un bambino non ci rendiamo
conto che da 0 a 10 anni e una una
spugna assorbe tutto quello che ci viene
detto le paticamente comunque cosa info
qualunque formazione lui riesce a sapere
la prima versione più intelligente con
sé stessi e da 0 a 10 anni né con degli
esseri così intelligenti come che
parliamo per bebè
e papà chi mi mordo consumo nato che
potrebbe sembrarci non spetta comincia a
fare bene chi è papà che alla mia testa
pensavo minchia speriamo che
l'infermiera poi il bambino comincia a
fare domanda non vendiamo ma la risposta
al real e lo trattiamo come un
deficiente ma la piccola mamma perché
abbiamo castrato il cane cioè perché
volevamo bene perché abbiamo passato il
gatto perché volevamo bene poi la notte
ma dentro nella stanza lo sai che ti
voglio bene ma chi ti conosce
noi perdiamo l'occasione è così a scuola
a scuola io dico evolviamo facciamo
sempre le stesse cose i programmi sono
uguali i programmi di storia sono gli
stessi che faceva mia madre mai successo
un sacco di roba come si fa ad andare a
rimanere fermi
com'è possibile l'inglese ancora e
facciamo noi glielo dico che ci
ascolteranno pure fuori dal tetto quindi
non è tutto quello che in inglese
impariamo in italia non faremo sul
tavolo the pen is on the table de curtis
on the table the car vision e la grotta
sono talora entrate una stanza non c'era
un tavolo faccione ragazzi non so
parlare
[Musica]
io l'evoluzione non deve essere solo la
tecnologia
probabilmente qualcuno lo sento che può
essere da domani comincia a fare the pen
drive sono dei tablet
no non è l'evoluzione deve essere
proprio nell'utilizzo nell'insegnare
come utilizzarlo perché tra l'altro non
solo crea in nuove nella fabietti
funzionale nuovi potenziali haters ma se
non insegni l'utilizzo di cellulari dai
manga uno strumento così forte un
bambino così piccolo
poi creare dei nuovi fan user perché il
mondo del web
tinti stica a mentire smentiamo di
continuo esattamente come la storia che
ho fatto all'inizio di questo talk voi
comunque abbiamo fatto lo scherzetto
siamo false ma sul web verrà fuori che a
questo tocca è piaciuto pure se qualcuno
è piaciuto quindi il web cistica
raccontava una vita molto più bella di
quella che moralmente noi alziamo
continuamente le aspettative questa cosa
nella vita non conviene mangiato il
principe azzurro con la principessa la
principessa si sposa il principe azzurro
perché prima era ranocchia quindi aveva
l'aspettativa è molto più basse poi a
paragone lui sembra bellissimo ma se lui
lei direttamente vedeva questo qua
biondo con i leggins blu gonna azzurro e
corpetto cioè l'essere spallino e blues
oper cavallo ma che che si sarebbe
sposato puffetta che fa quotazione
nessuno quindi abbassare aspettativa e
conviene
e questo poi genera tra l'altro il
cyberbullismo perché mette un mezzo così
forte ma non bambina e bambino non può
gestire che un problema enorme il cyber
bullismo è evidente i caffè bullismo c'è
sempre esistito e non è quello che
raccontano i film americani non funziona
che i bulli rubano le merendine anche
perché sono per domani sarebbe facile
basterebbe controllare la glicemia
non è quello il bullismo in realtà è
quando scrivevamo sui muri dei bagni
quello è cretino quello che schiavone
volete bagno è esattamente quello che
fanno oggi coi social ed è l'unica
differenza tra i social e muri dei bagni
e che non so per quale principale monete
bagnino disegnavamo sempre piselli che
non ho mai capito
ma poi fatte male sto dico se in bagno
coppia lo fanno bene però la
ora scusa ora il principio è questo che
noi prendiamo una cosa come questa e la
sottovalutiamo perché non ci arrabbiamo
abbastanza
e assurdo che non scendiamo in piazza
perché non viziata la mia education
sarebbe uno dei motivi per cui dovremmo
fare come pazzi
dovremmo arrabbiarci perché la rabbia
vedete una delle cose più belle che ci
hanno mai regalato la rabbia è una di
quelle caratteristiche di quelle armi di
quelle cose che possono trasformarsi in
poesia invece una lezione abituati a
demonizzarla io mi arrabbiavo anche a
scuola nella stessa scuola quando vi
dico che i programmi sono assurdi o io
vivo in più penso filosofia filosofia
sono nati 250.000 filosofi dopo hegel
kant freud ma noi siamo sempre stesse
che tra l'altro hanno una caratteristica
i filosofi che si chiama scuola loro si
arrabbiava nota di loro si contraddicono
per difenderlo
infatti non ho capito ma perché mi fa
studiare tra lax e poi aristotele lo
contraddistinse contratti contratti
professori ceva si contraddicono perché
non si capiscano appieno che ne so freud
ha contraddetto è che le perché lo capì
appieno è che la conta detto canto
perché non lo capiva pieno poi mi
interno dice me lo spieghi canta minima
lo ha capito è che lo dovrà aver quindi
e io penso che la rabbia come sharon i
filosofi dopo averlo anche noi perché la
rabbia fatto le cose più belle nella
storia dante era arrabbiato e metteva la
gente all'inferno ci ha scritto la
divina commedia
cioè quando un arrabbiato crea genera se
non vi fosse arrabbiato quando non
andavo bene all'università di medicina
diciamo 3 mm ma che devo fare la vita
nova e mai fatto il comico se non mi
fosse arrabbiato quando è in pizzeria ma
mi ascoltava non avrei mai sordido sul
web
se non mi fosse arrabbiato ogni volta
che potevano l'evento come fatto mai
niente c'è momento in cui uno cresce
momento in cui si arrabbia e costruisce
è così come quando l'ho fatto per
esempio se a tutti mafiosi e noi veniamo
da una terra la sicilia dove c'era la
più grande feki rus della storia ci
raccontavano che la mafia non esisteva
solo che c'è gente che sarà avviata
giudici giornalisti che oggi purtroppo
non ci sono più
si sono arrabbiati perché era piena
zeppa questa terra di analfabeti
funzionale ma non solo questa sera tutto
il paese un po tutto il mondo che
credevano alle norme fake nevose che la
mafia non esistesse loro ci sono più ma
hanno lottato ogni volta che lo si
arrabbia cambia le cose
io nel mio piccolo ho faccio un mestiere
che quando mi arrabbio scrivo scrivo
comicità perché abbiamo dove sfogarmi
e anche oggi quello che sto facendo qui
è una piccola forma di terapia perché io
quando mia mamma ha avuto il tumore oggi
fortuna sta bene e prevede un con
scritto la maggior parte delle battute
che ho detto poco fa in questo talk
quindi ogni volta che noi ci arrabbiamo
senza volerlo creiamo qui dobbiamo
arrabbiarci se oggi c'è gente che non
capisce le battute lo dice gente che va
a votare non coscientemente se oggi c'è
gente che non sa utilizzare un cellulare
tutti quanti
marra biaggi che quando uno si arrabbia
riesce nelle imprese anche le più
impossibili la zanzara
[Musica]